All right. Gil Ben Artzy,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Absolutely.
Thank you so much for having me.
You already told me you're gonna cheat
on the last question.
So, I'm so excited
for this interview because
it's gonna be I think different
from all the rest.
Gil, we know each other for many
many years now.
Ever since I think I came to visit you in Palo Alto
like six years ago for Anymeal,
the diet startup.
Gil, give me two, three sentences
about Upwest
and what you guys do.
I had an episode with Shuly but
it's so amazing that we have
to talk about it again.
There you go.
So, you can compare notes
and see if we're doing a good job.
I want to see if you're consistant
There you go.
So, Upwest is an early stage seed fund.
We actually invest in both pre-seed
and seed stage.
And we are tailor-made
for Israeli founders
that are looking to break
into the US market.
So, we are focused on investing
in Israeli founders
and helping them in the early stages
of ramping up the team,
getting momentum,
fund raising and so forth, here in the US.
We've done it for close to nine years now.
We've backed over 80 companies
that raised
over, well over, one billion dollars
in follow and financing.
First investor in ... which is
a Unitcon startup and many other
prominent companies that
we think at least
a few will reach that stage.
So, we've been super excited to do this
for a while now. And yeah, I'm looking for
the future ahead.
Amazing. So, I always joked
with new funds
that when you start out, the lifetime
of a company is like, what, seven to nine years
That's the game you're going in to.
So, usually the first few years it can kind of go
along without showing
too many returns
because it takes seven to nine years.
But you're there. So, now you have to
show returns and obviously
you've showing
some pretty amazing returns
or you've shown amazing companies
and where they're at now.
What is this idea of Israelis
in Silicon Valley
and this integration and adaptation?
So, first of all, eight, nine years in VC
is very very young.
I'm still learning every day.
It's the equivalent of maybe eight,
nine months
in the startups.
So, we've been around for a while
but it takes
time, decades. You know, I think Israel
always had a very special relationship
with the US.
But on the tech funds, specifically with
the valley, you've seen over the years
fantastic companies emerge here.
And in the last couple of decades
in particular,
many fantastic companies, such as House
and others have emerged here by really
incredible Israeli founders.
And our goal is to level the playing fields
for Israeli companies
that wanna come here
and get the same opportunities that
other founders that are
already based here.
Amazing. Gil, how many companies,
how many decks do you read a year?
We see well over a thousand. We invest in
far less than one percent.
And what, the way
we think about it is not about
screening them and stuff.
I mean, we spend a lot of time
in Israel and
here and whether its Zoom or in person,
our goal is really also to give feedback.
Like we wanna contribute to their journey.
Give them some insights
about the market.
Maybe a few competitors that maybe
had not heard about or know, you know
or we can add more information about.
So, we really wanna help them and advise them
because they deserve it.
Incredible. I don’t know many people
who can talk about their job and say that
after nine years of being in the same
quote unquote job
they're still learning every day
and it feels like
they were only there for
eight or nine months.
So, already I'm inspired by this passion.
Gil, where do you come from?
You have a pretty interesting leeway.
Yeah. So, Israeli you're talking right.
My first nine years I, I was actually born
in Be'er Sheva. When my parents were
in their very early 20s and going to university.
So, I was born in Be'er Sheva but
I grow up my first nine years in Kfar Saba.
We then moved to London.
I spend seven years growing up
in London.
I can feel it in the accent.
The accent and definitely my passion for
specific music and sports emerged there.
What is that passion? What is that music?
Well, growing up in London
in the 80s, right.
You get attached to certain types of music
and take it with you.
But yeah. I'm definitely, like discovering
new music on a numbering basis.
I think that's where it began.
Came back to Israel sixteen.
Back to Kfar Saba. Did my military service.
Wasn’t smart enough to be in 8200
and so forth. I'm the oldest
of three siblings, so I'm
the alpha version.
The alpha version is ...
So, my brother and sister did much better
than me at school.
But I spend three years in the armed corps,
did my undergrad, and at the age of 25,
I decided that I want to break into
the US market on my own. Right?
No real tech background but I did wanna
know that I wanted to spend
some time here.
And moved here to do
my MBA at Wharton.
Worked for BCG in New York
and then Yahoo and here we are.
Amazing. And what did you do at Yahoo?
I started off in the
Corporate Development team
which was amazing exposure. Got to work
with fantastic people and even
the founders of Yahoo.
Being Israeli, I send myself
to Israel once or
twice a year. To see startups. Help them.
But also ended up acquiring Yahoo's
first company in Israel. Helping to open
the first R&D center in Haifa.
And it's actually where the seeding of sort
of Upwest began when
I met Shuly in 2006
and we start ...
start differences between some of
the founders here and some of
the founders in Israel that were at least
on the same level in terms of their DNA
but maybe didn’t have
the same opportunities
of those that were
already based in the US.
Incredible. I mean I was just such
a small kid.
You're saying Yahoo.
That was about 2005, 2006?
Started in '05
spent 4 years in CopDev and
2 years in operations. Yes.
At that time I had my Yahoo mailbox
and all my friends had a Yahoo mailbox.
It was obviously a different time back then
in terms of the market share of the companies.
But that's incredible. And Gil,
you have the unique experience
of being a partner in quite a few
portfolio companies. How many
portfolio companies
do you see through now?
Over the past nine years?
How many have we invested or seen?
Right yeah invested in. That you're a part of their journey.
Invested in, 82.
82. Okay.
So, you have the unique privilege
and the challenging role
to come in to this incredibly difficult time
over the past three months and
you have to help 82 companies or
a little less go through this journey of
dealing with Covid-19
and you actually have to do it also
with a newborn. Congratulations.
Thank you.
Beautiful Maya. What is that like?
What is your role as the VC partner and
helping these portfolio companies
push through this?
So, first of all it's not individual support,
right.
I mean it's myself, my partners,
but also the other well investors
that back the companies.
And I think for us it's giving a sanity check
to the founders and also helping spread
information what others are doing.
So, for example in the very beginning,
it's really encouraging them to take a
close look at their runway and not be shy
in making decisions,
some of them tough, about their workforce
because the longer you procrastinate
and say,
"You know, we'll have to wait."
the more painful it become afterwards.
So, it’s having those eyes wide
open conversation.
Did you have a situation
where you pushed
a founder to make that difficult decision
and you feel like if you weren't in the picture
they might not have been able to make it?
Yeah, I wouldn’t say pushed them.
I think maybe pushed them to think about
other alternatives.
And sometimes it’s not just about us.
It's about connecting them
maybe to other founders.
We also brought people
that were, back in 2008
so the previous recession,
and had to overcome that.
So, it's not just about what I know,
what I think.
It's about sort of being sort of
their advisor and shepherding them
through the process.
And do you approach this optimistically,
pessimistically, or realistically? What's your
position at the dinner table with your
founding team?
You know there's no pessimist
in the world
there's only optimist and realist. Right?
I think as a venture capitalist, as a founder
you have to have some heavy dose
of optimism. Right? It makes no sense to
start a company and try to battle these
incredible giants or overcome of
the obstacle.
So, you need to have this
level of optimism.
So, we do go into it. But at the same time
you need to plan for the worst
and the worst is
you need to have 18, 24 months of
runway for example.
And not just say, "You know, this will be a
V-shaped recovery and in three months
everything will be fine."
You know what? Let's all hope so
that’s the case but let's plan for it
not being whatsoever that.
Amazing. Gil, what excites you?
After nine years, thousands
of potential deals,
82 investments.
What gets you up in the morning?
What are you really really excited about?
Lots of things. I don't think I'm one of
those investors that says,
"This domain or that domain."
I think for me it really comes to the people
that we meet at a coffee shop,
on the corner of Rothschild Avenue
and something in Tel Aviv.
When they only have the gleam in their eyes
and they just started and it's about trying
to see if sort of we can help guide them through
come to the US and growing their business
to become what we think it can become.
So, I think it's that optimism, that belief,
those early days, the process,
the ups, the downs.
I think the journey itself
is what excites me.
Certainly new technologies
impact on the world
I am completely on board. But it's I think
being part of the journey of one person
against the world, quote unquote
that I like being part of.
And how would you describe your
engagement with them?
Some VCs are very hands-off,
take my money and leave.
Sort of dumb money.
Some of them are, come sit in our offices
giving a small ...
but how do you approach
this relationship of yours with your
portfolio companies
at such an early stage?
Yeah. Look, I think each investor
wants to contribute. I think each investor
plays a different role.
So, at the very beginning
we are almost always
the first and only money in the company.
So, it's about typically guiding them in the
right direction.
Avoiding making big mistakes.
Helping them make some decision that
early on. Helping them to find additional
investor that can invest.
And overtime that evolves because now
they have different advisors that bring
something else to the table.
So, for us we have to ask ourselves "Okay,
how do we change
our position and advice
to compliment
some of the other people that are
supporting the CEO and the founders?"
So, even our role changes over time.
No totally, but at the end also,
I got to be in the
Upwest offices quite a few times
at this point.
It's practically my second home outside
of the Stanford dorms.
You walk in and you see five, six
different companies sitting in their tables
talking to each other. All friends.
Everybody's so nice. It's kind of like a hub.
It reminds me of the Google campus
that was back in Electra Building
you know
a few years ago where you walk in
and there's this electricity and fire.
And it doesn’t look like it’s a VC office.
It looks like it’s a workspace where
you're not just giving money
to the portfolio companies.
You're actually giving mentorship and friendship.
And a community for them to work together
in the heart of Silicon Valley
which is not, away from Tel Aviv
where they get to be with other Israelis
right in the same room.
Yeah. Two things about it.
You're completely right.
First of all the community.
Critical word for us.
It's about founders going, share
their experiences that actually are
pretty unique to them
when you think about it.
You move to the US. You come with you're
significant other with kids. Many of them.
That's not easy whatsoever.
So, you share the experiences,
both companies at the same stage
but also those that came
one, two, five years
ahead of you.
So, we make sure
to bring all that to the table.
But the second thing is, we absolutely
make sure that folks are not sort of
sitting within themselves.
It's about pushing them out immersing
in the ecosystem. Just because the culture
of the business here can be
at first challenging
and not that straightforward to understand.
I'm still figuring it out. Right?
So, almost a couple of decades onwards.
So, it's about definitely being out there.
It's very easy to get in to your shell and be
with your own folks
but you absolutely have
to be out there to succeed.
Definitely.
Are things changing in the VC world?
What's happening?
Are things have been the same
over the past few decades?
Where do you see things going forward
not just with Upwest but general
venture capital relationship with entrepreneurs
let's say in the next decade?
Yeah. I don’t know if I'm smart enough
to sort of see the next decade,
but there's definitely
in the last 10 years plus
have been some definite big changes.
I think the definition of venture capital
has changed what VCs bring to the table.
Many firms have taken that to add
lots of experiences and value adds
in various ways
so it's not just the partners in the fund.
Funds of all sizes. Right?
In the past seed funds,
What is a seed fund? Anything below 50
100 didn’t make any sense.
Now you have super ...
seed funds.
That happened a decade ago.
So, began at least really fantastic funds there.
Obviously the soft bank phenomena
and funds not raising 300 but 3 billion
and even 100 billion as we saw.
So, things have changed a lot.
But the covid hasn’t evolved
which is trying to get conviction
about a team hoping that they get
conviction about you
because you are about to spend seven
to 10 years working together.
Hopefully.
So, you want this mutual respect - exactly
hopefully - mutual respect, mutual ability
to work together. So, finding those
partnerships founders is not easy.
It actually shouldn’t be easy.
It's a big decision for both sides.
That hasn’t changed.
Right. Gil, now I'm talking as the young entrepreneur.
I get to surround myself with incredible
other young entrepreneurs
much smarter than me
both from 8200 and Stanford.
I'm just amazed by the things
that some of them are doing.
And it's very confusing.
There's a lot of options.
A lot of places to go.
How does a young entrepreneur
balance their journey? On one hand
there's this pride and I'm gonna go
raise money and I'm gonna finish
my culminator and raise the biggest
seed round I can raise.
The other hand you have the
more conservative approach of,
I'm not sure that I need money.
I can maybe bootstrap this or maybe
I'm looking for specific strategic investors.
So, how does a young entrepreneur
like myself navigate
through all these options
and what's the most important thing
to keep in mind as I'm building my team,
as I'm building my strategy to eventually
make a big impact?
Good question. So, first of all
there's no one way. Right?
There’s no one way that treats everything.
For young founders, I think it's about
surrounding yourself with the right
set of advisors, of friends, and experiences
that you gather along the way
and see what works for you.
Sometimes it's about getting you're
knowledgeable about business
that you're super passionate about
and you can make it into a bootstrap
and you can work with it before fundraising
if at all.
Sometimes you have maybe some
technical skills, a unique team that you
put together that you really have to raise
a meaningful seed to show something
meaningful at the early stage.
So, there's no one answer. But I think
I would encourage everyone to, especially
in Stanford, make those internships
count during the years,
during the summer.
Make them as diverse as human impossible.
Reach out to people. Have coffee chat,
coffee chats.
I actually, I think as my journey
took me here,
I spoke to many dozens
of venture capitalists
before even knowing what that is
and deciding to jump into the deep end.
And this is 10 years post MBA. So, I took
full advantage of my person network,
my business profession networks,
to just talk to people
and see what they say and what
they've learned and their experiences.
And then figure out the right path for me.
And the right path for me was not
to join a big VC,
but we had the opportunity
to start our own, Shuly and me, and bootstrap
it if you can believe it
at the very beginning.
So, that was the answer for us.
Does that mean that's the answer
for everyone in our profession? No.
Sure. Yeah no
It seems like there is a growing trend
where relationships are not so much
about the long term
but its more about
what can you offer me today
so that and I can offer you something tomorrow
which is kind of disheartening and you see it with a
competitive nature, I think.
Sometimes at a place like Stanford
there’s a lot others
who are very interested in
forming these personal relationships.
I value them a lot
and that's why I love doing
what we're doing here and getting to
know you over these years
and hopefully one day
I can be in front of you
and I'll be one of the thousands decks
that you receive in your mailbox.
So, hopefully sooner than later.
Gil, last thoughts about
where are you headed with this?
Do you see yourself continuing with Upwest,
growing it into a massive VC?
Do you see yourself navigating potentially
to other areas? What's up with you?
So, as much as I can help it
and control things
this is the last job I wanna be doing,
right.
... anything else.
It's our startup. Right? This is our startup.
This is a startup?
Upwest is a startup. We bootstrap it.
We raise money from people.
We're trying to grow to a certain extent.
But that's sort of what we do. Right?
I even asked you in the email. I asked you
I thought that we might talk about
being a VC versus starting a startup
but you're actually starting a startup
while doing a VC.
Yeah. So, and I absolutely treat it that way.
I'm going forward. We're doing a scale
a little bit.
But ultimately what will guide us is
we wanna invest in very early stage
startups founded by Israelis,
whoever they are, and help them break
into the US market.
If we raise too much money,
it doesn’t make sense to write
a pre-seed or seed check.
We now have to be a serious
A fund which
a.) is less fun for me
b.) there's so many better investors.
So many better investors than us to do it.
So, we wanna specialize in being
that first check.
And so, we have to right size the fund
so we can’t raise too much. Right?
Gil, three words that best describe you
and now I'm ready for the cheating.
So, the cheating is
I'm a big fan of hyphens.
I will be hyphenating a little bit here.
So, on sort of the business side,
I aspired to be a trusted advisor.
So, that's a hyphenated word.
That's what I would like to continue to be
and aspire to be and hopefully
I can continue perfecting that.
On a personal level, as you see me
sitting in e pink room here,
I will take on the
description of a simple, of like a father.
I'm still figuring it out and will likely
figure it out for a long time.
So, that would be my second word
and I didn’t cheat here.
That's not hyphenated.
I love it. So, it looks kind of white
but now I'll make it clear
this is a pink room. Gil, is sitting
in your daughter's room, right?
Yeah, light pink room. Exactly.
And then the third,
I didn’t know what to say.
So, I'll just go with, and this is absolutely
hyphenated ...
I'm a proud dual citizen of Israel and the US.
But where I grew up, my roots
is from ...
and what that means to me is
community, family,
and that is where I'm from
and where I started.
And frankly, all my family,
cousins, aunts, about 40 close members
of my family all live five minutes from
one another. Walking distance.
And I'm the only one who isn’t.
So, I'm like the black sheep of the family.
But yeah, that's what hyphenated values
to describe myself.
Gil, toda raba. Best of luck.
It sounds amazing.
And look for my email with the deck
in one or two years.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me.
Take care.